(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Muitas pessoas, antes de participar de um leilão
e antes de estudar como é que funciona,
têm dúvida porque sabem que o único bem
de uma pessoa tem proteção legal.
Então, nessa aula, a gente vai acabar com
essa dúvida e você vai aprender todas as
exceções que podem fazer com que, mesmo que
seja o único bem de uma pessoa, que
esse bem possa ser leiloado e não vai
existir nenhum problema quanto a isso.
Então, vamos lá.
O que é bem de família?
Bem de família é exatamente o único bem
que uma pessoa ou uma entidade familiar possua.
Esse bem de família é protegido por lei.
A lei diz que a regra é que
esse bem de família é impenhorável.
Isso significa dizer que esse bem de família
não vai poder responder por dívidas de seus
proprietários.
Então, mesmo que o proprietário deva para um
monte de gente, seu bem vai ficar resguardado
e ele não vai poder ser penhorado e
depois ser leiloado para quitar as dívidas de
seu proprietário.
Mas, como toda regra, existem exceções.
Essa regra da impenhorabilidade do bem de família
não é absoluta.
Ela possui exceções.
São sete exceções previstas em lei e a
gente vai estudar aqui a partir desse momento.
Então, saiba que se o caso se enquadrar
em alguma dessas exceções, não interessa se aquele
devedor ou se aquela entidade familiar só possui
aquele bem.
Aquele bem será leiloado normalmente.
Não existe nenhuma unidade quanto a isso.
Não existe nenhum risco de você participar daquele
leilão porque a lei resguarda essas exceções.
Vamos lá, então, para a primeira exceção.
São os processos movidos pelos titulares do crédito
decorrente do financiamento destinado à construção ou aquisição
do imóvel no limite dos créditos e acréscimos
constituídos em função do respectivo contrato.
Então, vamos supor, você fez uma compra de
um imóvel, mas você não tinha o dinheiro
inteiro daquele imóvel e você financiou.
Ou você comprou um terreno e queria construir
uma casa, mas também não tinha o dinheiro
dessa casa, você pegou um financiamento para te
proporcionar que aquela construção acontecesse.
Caso você deixe de pagar esse financiamento, não
existe nenhum empecilho que seu imóvel seja apenhorado
e depois seja levado a leilão para a
cobrança dessa dívida.
Exatamente porque essa dívida foi constituída para adquirir
o imóvel ou para financiar a construção do
imóvel e essa é a primeira exceção legal.
Segunda exceção, pelo credor da pensão alimentícia.
Então, quando alguém deve uma pensão alimentícia para
outra pessoa, nós teremos de um lado o
devedor da pensão alimentícia e do outro lado
o credor da pensão alimentícia.
Esse credor da pensão alimentícia, para cobrar o
devedor da pensão, deverá mover um processo judicial
e nesse processo judicial, realmente o devedor vai
ser condenado a pagar uma quantia X do
que ele está em atraso naquela pensão alimentícia.
Caso ele não tenha dinheiro, não tenha veículo
e aquela regrinha que a gente falou da
ordem de preferência da lei para pagamentos das
dívidas, pode recair no imóvel dele.
E aí não importa se aquele é o
único imóvel, é um imóvel de moradia, aquele
imóvel vai ser apenhorado e vai ser leiloado
para o pagamento dessa dívida de pensão alimentícia.
Terceira exceção, para cobrança de impostos, taxas, contribuições
devidas em função do imóvel familiar.
Ou seja, aqui nesse caso entram as dívidas
de IPTU se o imóvel for urbano ou
ITR se o imóvel for rural.
E também nessa exceção da lei entram as
dívidas de condomínio.
Então aqui a gente está falando talvez da
exceção que faça com que maior número de
leilões judiciais aconteça, que é exatamente por cobrança
de cotas condominais.
Então quando você se deparar com um leilão
que tem origem, uma cobrança de cotas condominais,
não importa se aquele imóvel é o único
imóvel da pessoa, se aquele imóvel é um
imóvel de moradia da pessoa.
O leilão vai acontecer normalmente, o proprietário daquele
imóvel vai perder o seu imóvel e vai
ter que desocupar aquele leilão.
Veja, essa exceção da lei é muito óbvia.
Imagine que alguém compre um imóvel e depois
não tenha a menor capacidade financeira para pagar
o valor de condomínio mensal daquele imóvel.
Não seria justo que aquela pessoa pudesse morar
naquele imóvel por anos e que o condomínio
não tivesse meios de fazer aquela cobrança.
Isso seria onerar de forma injustificada todos os
demais moradores daquele condomínio.
Afinal de contas, quando um condomínio não recebe
o que é devido por um morador, o
custo do condomínio não diminui.
A despesa é fixa.
Continua tendo despesa com conservação, com os funcionários
do condomínio.
Então aquela despesa vai ser repassada para todos
os outros moradores.
Então todos os outros moradores vão arcar com
aquela parcela que os inadimplentes não estão pagando
naquele condomínio.
Então veja, é óbvio isso.
A pessoa não tem condições de morar naquele
lugar.
Ela não pode continuar morando naquele lugar.
Não importa se aquele é o único imóvel
dela.
A mesma coisa é para dívidas tributárias relacionadas
ao imóvel.
Se você tem um imóvel, você tem que
ter capacidade financeira de pagar o IPTU daquele
imóvel se for um imóvel urbano.
Se você tem um imóvel rural, você tem
que ter capacidade financeira de pagar o ITR
daquele imóvel.
Se for para cobrança, então, de dívidas tributárias
relacionadas a imóvel e cobrança de cotas condominais
relacionadas a imóveis dentro de condomínios, perfeitamente possível
essa exceção do bem de família.
Não importa se aquele é o único bem,
o leilão vai acontecer normalmente.
Quarta exceção da lei.
Execução de hipoteca sobre o imóvel oferecido como
garantia real para quitar o empréstimo.
O que é a hipoteca?
A hipoteca é um empréstimo feito por um
banco e como garantia para o pagamento daquele
empréstimo, o devedor do empréstimo vai oferecer um
imóvel que ele tenha.
Então também não seria nem um pouco plausível
que o devedor oferecesse um imóvel e depois
se valesse da exceção à empenhorabilidade do bem
de família.
Veja, eu fui ao banco, peguei uma hipoteca,
não pago nada da hipoteca e depois eu
posso virar para o banco e falar olha,
eu te dei esse imóvel como garantia, mas
você não pode penhorar esse meu imóvel porque
a lei diz que meu imóvel é empenhorado.
Qual seria a garantia do banco então?
Nenhuma, porque você deu um imóvel que o
banco não pode penhorar.
Então é perfeitamente possível também que o banco
penhore um imóvel que ele teve como garantia
para o pagamento de um empréstimo feito através
de uma hipoteca.
Quinta exceção, se o imóvel for adquirido como
produto de crime ou para execução de uma
sentença penal condenatória a ressarcimento, indenização ou perdimento
de bens.
Ou seja, alguém cometeu um crime e aí
com proveito desse crime comprou imóveis.
Não seria nem um pouco plausível também que
após a pessoa ser condenada por aquele crime
aquele imóvel permanecesse em sua esfera patrimonial.
Afinal de contas ela comprou aquele imóvel com
dinheiro que não era dela que foi de
um proveito de um crime, então também vai
perder.
E a mesma coisa também se for uma
sentença penal condenatória a ressarcimento, indenização ou perdimento
de bens.
Então vamos supor, alguém cometeu um crime de
homicídio culposo e matou outra pessoa sem ter
ali a intenção de matar aquela pessoa mas
a pessoa veio a óbito.
Quem matou vai responder um processo por esse
homicídio culposo.
Pode ser que ao final desse processo o
próprio juiz criminal fale que a pessoa que
matou deve pagar indenização a alguma outra pessoa,
a algum familiar.
E nesse caso também não importa se aquele
bem seria o único bem daquele devedor, a
pessoa que cometeu um crime aquele bem vai
poder ser normalmente penhorado, leiloado para satisfazer aquele
crédito que a pessoa está devendo.
Outra exceção, por obrigação decorrente de fiança concedida
em contrato de locação.
Essa também é uma exceção que faz muito
imóvel ir a leilão.
Então em primeiro lugar nós temos ali as
dívidas de condomínio.
São disparados os maiores números de casos de
leilão judicial.
Em segundo lugar eu arriscaria dizer que fica
aqui no caso de fiança.
Se alguém foi fiador de outra pessoa, esse
fiador tem que estar efetivamente preparado para pagar
as dívidas daquela pessoa.
Então se a pessoa não pagar, o fiador
vai ser acionado.
Se o fiador for acionado e também não
pagar em dinheiro, ele pode ter seus bens
penhorados normalmente.
E também não importa se é o único
bem do fiador, se é bem de família
do fiador, se o fiador mora naquele imóvel.
O problema é do fiador.
Ninguém mandou o fiador garantir a dívida de
ninguém.
Tenha isso em mente também.
Só seja fiador de uma pessoa que você
confie muito e se você efetivamente estiver preparada
para pagar a dívida daquela pessoa.
Porque senão seu único imóvel pode entrar ali
no jogo para pagar a dívida daquela pessoa
que você garantiu através de uma fiança.
Para cobrança de crédito constituído pela Procuradoria Geral
Federal em decorrência de benefício previdenciário ou assistencial
recebido indevidamente por dolo, fraude ou coação, inclusive
por terceiro que sabia ou deveria saber da
origem ilícita dos recursos.
Então esse aqui é basicamente o mesmo exemplo
lá da sentença penal condenatória.
A pessoa adquiriu aquele imóvel por um dinheiro
que ela não teria direito.
Ela fraudou um benefício previdenciário ou fraudou e
repassou esse dinheiro para terceiro, esse terceiro também
sabia que o produto era de uma fraude.
Nenhuma dessas pessoas pode alegar bem de família.
Compraram o imóvel com dinheiro que não era
delas.
Então, normalmente também, o imóvel também vai a
leilão e vai poder ser penhorado sem maior
problema.
Então aqui são as sete exceções que a
lei apresenta e você precisa saber essas exceções
muito bem porque você precisa acabar com aquele
medo que a maioria da população que não
sabe como funcionam os leilões, não entende como
funcionam as leis, acham que se for o
único bem da pessoa, a pessoa não pode
ter aquele bem levado à leilão.
Isso não existe para as exceções.
Então nessas exceções não interessa quantos imóveis aquela
pessoa tem, não interessa se a pessoa está
morando dentro daquele imóvel, o imóvel vai ser
levado à leilão e a emissão na posse
vai acontecer de forma normal.
O arrematante vai ter direito normalmente a entrar
naquele imóvel.
Não é problema do arrematante se aquele devedor
só tem aquele imóvel.
Isso não é uma questão que o arrematante
deve se preocupar.
O arrematante deve saber o que?
O que a lei diz sobre as exceções.
Então se você bater um olho lá de
dívida de fiança, dívida de condomínio, não interessa.
Você não precisa se preocupar.
Será que esse cara aqui tem outro lugar?
Será que esse leilão depois pode ser anulado?
Não, o leilão não vai ser anulado.
Exceção prevista em lei.
A lei protege o arrematante nesse caso aqui.